[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est que je suis désolé Carl ce n'est
pas comme ça que j'aime faire les choses et ne le fais pas
vilain me demande ton passé écoute moi
attentivement fille tu es sur le point d'entrer dans l'
Animus de quoi tu parles  voir entendre et
sentir sont les souvenirs de quelqu'un
qui est mort depuis 500 ans garçon une minute
civilisation atteindre
commencer la régression
toi
[Musique]
jeter un coup d'oeil prendre
toi
[Applaudissements]
qui es-tu
ils m'appellent Musa
mais je m'appelle Baptiste  Je suis mort depuis 200
ans maintenant foudre empoisonneur je suis en train de
récolter  la lame de
l'assassin c'est celle que votre père a utilisée
pour ôter la vie à sa mère il est là vous
savez la mort de sa mère vous ne savez pas
quelque chose qu'un garçon devrait
voir
[Musique]
l'histoire du monde est l'histoire
de la violence l'
humanité semble déterminée à  se détruisant
mais il y a un artefact connu sous le nom de
pomme d'Eden w  Avec lui, toute impulsion
vers l'indépendance ou l'abélien sera
écrasée, nous avons placé les protecteurs de l'
artefact, toutes les lignées sont
mortes sauf une,
son nom est Callum Lynch, je suis médecin
Sofia RIKEN, je suis ici pour vous aider et vous
êtes ici pour  aidez-moi comment allez-vous les gens
nous savons tout sur vous Karl
nous cherchions quelque chose et nous avons besoin que
vous l'obteniez pour nous
vous êtes sur le point d'entrer dans l'Animus ce que
vous êtes sur le point de voir entendre et ressentir sont
les souvenirs de  votre ancêtre qui est
mort depuis 500 ans
drôle dur pour moi votre message attendez une
minute
bienvenue à l'Inquisition espagnole
ce que j'ai vu là-
dedans c'était réel c'était vous leur donnez la
pomme et ils gagnent
les Templiers l'utiliseront pour nous détruire
mais maintenant  pionnier moi bien
je commence à aimer ça
[Musique]
tu es destiné à de grandes faveurs c'est
bien maintenant
nous travaillons dans le darf affirmons la lumière nous
sommes des assassins sus ins et les templiers
sont en guerre depuis des siècles les assassins
croient que par dessus tout
l'humanité devrait h  ave libre arbitre les
tempéraments sont plus intéressés par le pouvoir et
un moyen de contrôler la race humaine toutes les
lignées que les assassins guident sur la première
barre
son nom est Callum Lynch
qu'apprenez-vous de moi
vos anciens
assassins s'assurent que la liberté
est toujours protectrice  et chéris ne répondez pas
tous morts entre vos mains maintenant
l'obscurité sert la lumière nous sommes des
assassins
le concept d'assassins et de templiers se
battant à travers les siècles est une
expérience cinématographique fantastique c'est
original et inventif
nous travaillons dans l'obscurité
monsieur c'est une lumière hé les gars  qu'est-ce que vous, nous
sommes des assassins, le film d'Assassin's
Creed, je veux juste que ce soit une
balade incroyable qui vous mène dans
des séquences d'action dynamiques
et elles sont vraiment excitantes et nous
essayons de nous baser autant que possible sur la
réalité.  m le plus ancien Michael compréhensible dans
le film, le personnage de Michael Fassbender
est piégé et il doit sauter un acte de
foi en
sautant 125 pieds normalement, ce serait un personnage
numérique  cter qui sauterait
le meilleur de Damien donc nous allons le
faire pour de vrai Justin veut que ce soit aussi
réel que possible nous allons dans le
monde réel nous ne comptons pas sur les
effets visuels nous commençons bas avec le premier
le saut est juste une question de déterminer un
moment à l'arbre car l'
empreinte réelle du sac n'est que de 10 mètres
sur 10 mètres, donc lorsque vous êtes là-haut, il
ressemble à peu près à la taille d'un papier de quatre morceaux
allant à nouveau à la verticale de 7 pieds
dans le sac trop lourd alors mettez un peu de
bouillie à l'arrière de la tête alors essayez de
ne pas faire ça trois deux
[Applaudissements]
c'est le meilleur moment quand vous
partez et
partez  un missile
je comprends que c'est ton anniversaire ouais la
fête ne fait que commencer
son nom est Callan Minj nous avons retracé sa
lignée il y a cinq cents ans jusqu'à la
vache Assassin's Creed comme n'importe qui dans le monde sait ou se
soucie que tu n'existes plus
quel est cet endroit
ce  c'est ta seconde chance
qu'est-ce que tu veux pour moi ton passé tu es
ab  sortir pour entrer dans l'Animus ce que vous voyez
entendre et ressentir sont les souvenirs de votre
ancêtre qui est mort depuis 500 ans
attendez une minute
bienvenue à l'Inquisition espagnole
là-bas et est tombé réel
[Musique
] c'était
vous vous regardiez en attendant de voir qui
tu es
[Musique]
Je crois que tu es destiné à de grandes
choses c'est bien maintenant
[Musique]
ils travaillent dans le noir servent les lumières
nous sommes des assassins
Je commence à aimer ça
[Applaudissements] le
mien à 18h  hier soir tu as
été exécuté et déclaré mort tu
n'existes plus quel genre de personne est-ce
ce n'est pas une prison tu vas entrer dans
l'Animus ce que tu vas voir entendre
et ressentir ce sont les souvenirs de ton
ancêtre qui est mort  pendant 500 ans
que voulez-vous de moi
votre passé
bienvenue à l'Inquisition espagnole je suis
Dieu même si je suis un homme de Dieu ma vie
entre les mains de Dieu vous avez tous mieux
vite
[Musique]
nous travaillons dans  le noir juste une sorte de délice
nous sommes des assassins
[Musique]
vous